[Music]  i'm  very very happy very very happy  very very i never believed  the joy is too much i can't quantify the  joy  god has done it we said that if we serve  god we will see our children and we have  seen them  as he has brought this child he will  bring the rest  you know that if you came before all  together now  we have received 34 out of the 121  we are still expecting 87 to come back  we called on all the people  that knew about security apart to assist  us  with information how could we reach  these people  [Music]  nearly 1 000 students have been  kidnapped from boarding schools in  nigeria's north  in may gunmen invaded an islamic school  in central nigeria  and kidnapped 136 students in broad  daylight  only five of them have so far been  [Music]  released  you